welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
in the trailer for the new first person
shooter Immortals of AVM just dropped
and oh my God does this game look
genuinely incredible mostly because it's
not your typical first person shooter oh
no ain't no bullets here only magic yo
so let's dive into this trailer together
to see just how Immortals of avium will
they you be the ultimate Defender
against the dark arts and thanks to EA
for sponsoring this video Immortals of
avium is a tactical first person Magic
based shooter made by the minds at
ascendant Studios that worked on titles
like dead space and Call of Duty The
Immortals of avian trailer opens with a
badass image of a dark wizard deflecting
a blue magic blast without a care with
their left hand before blasting a magic
Soldier using red magic with their right
hand and absolutely annihilating a group
of enemies with a devastating Mystic
beam attack I thought this was an
extremely dope and effective way to
Showcase what this game is all about
from the jump using three different
types of magic to fight in this Savage
War for the fate of this super
interesting mystical World by the name
of avium and in this world of AVM Blue
Magic is called Force magic green magic
is called life magic and red magic is
called chaos magic which is something
that I believe we all have some
familiarity with the following shot
shows us a bird's eye view of avian with
floating island that can be seen to the
right of the frame any statue of what
appears to be a past hero of avium
standing in the center here but what's
the most striking in this image are of
course the streaks of blue green and red
energy that are traced around the land
most likely to represent the Ley lines
of magic that run through the very veins
of the planet itself and I believe it is
this Rich magic land that the Immortals
of abium's two warring factions are
fighting over with These two factions
being the kingdom of lucium the good
guys and the theocracy of Rashad the bad
guys Immortals of avium has you playing
as Jack a battle mage in the Kingdom of
lucian's elite attack Squad known as The
Immortals as played by actor Darren
Barnett we see Jack in this next shot
using a piece of magic Tech on his right
hand called a Sigil just switch between
different types of colored magic in
order to outsmart his enemies in battle
for starting with green life magic blast
and switching to Red chaos magic and
then finishing his enemies off with a
powerful force ground pound this game
mechanic is one that I am super excited
about because it lets combat be
challenging and forces you to think on
the Fly and with over 25 spells and 80
towns to master as you explore over a
dozen different biomes Immortals of
avium seems to emphasize wanting you to
build your wizard your own way which I
love like enemies boss fights and a ton
of puzzles and side quests all encourage
players to use sigils and totems to
upgrade their magic to become more
diesel first-person Wizards like this
game looks freaking tight Point your
signal will help you focus your magic
prevent it from killing you
like I freaking love this shot of a
Lucian battle mage throwing a freaking
Force magic spear at a Rashard enemy and
seemingly breaking their Force Magic
Shield because in this game Blue Force
magic can break Blue Magic Shields and
red magic breaks red magic Shields and
green magic breaks green magic Shields
but even though their Shields broke here
it seems like the Battle Mages of
rashard's Mastery of the Blue Force
magic proved to be too much for these
Knights of lucium with theocracy of
Roshan's leader sandrak himself
unleashing a powerful force magic attack
on the ground that annihilates multiple
lucium soldiers at once it's kind of
like Earth bending and I freaking love
sandrax design so much man like that
demon mask ain't got no eyes in it son
it's like you're telling me that this
dude is kicking all of that ass
blindfolded like Jack and his friends
got some serious problems man but
speaking of Jack's three other Squad
mates on this Immortals team let's meet
him shall we there's a name for what you
are a Magnus I want to be an immortal I
want to fight this war as one of you one
of the it
I believe in you she definitely thinks
you're going to die that's why her face
looks like that first we have Gina
Torres a firefly Fame playing General
kirkin Jack's mentor and apparent leader
of the Immortals team we learn from the
end of the trailer that the general
found our main character Jack as a boy
and saw his potential to be a harmful
magic wielder so much so that she even
debated killing Jack when she met him as
a boy I found a child whose new powers
could make them a threat to the kingdom
I protect the choice was to either kill
you or turn you into a weapon
option A was to kill me then we have
Devin played by Actor Antonio Akil dress
in green and actress Lily Cowles as
zendara dressed in red and while the
main character Jack does wear blue he's
actually a little special something
called a triarch Magnus which allows
Jack to wield all three magic types Not
Just Blue Force magic seemingly like
General kirkin who wears a mixture of
red green and blue to denote a Mastery
of all three Magics I mean she's got to
be the leaders of the Immortals for a
reason y'all but I've gotta say here
zendara all right I don't mean to snip
okay but zandara is easily my favorite
character because she looks like an
absolute badass who would give me a
piggyback ride anytime that she wanted
I'm just saying I freaking love how she
blasts that chaos vashar and soldier
with her own chaos energy and is like do
Manaya old friends like are you kidding
me like that is wife material but
anyways it seems like the Immortals are
being tasked to stop Sandra of rashan
from hoarding all of avium's magic for
himself so that he can take over the
entire planet and the team at ascended
Studios seem to be dedicated to tell
that Tale in the form of an epic
action-packed first-person narrative
that makes you want to earn your
victories by using your brain and I'm
all about that like I'm tired of all
these pew pew pew bullet shooters that
are just so mindless I like to be a good
shooter that takes some thought and
strategy and Immortals of aviom seems
like that and more but anyways yeah this
is my analysis for this trailer for
immortals of amium this game looks
incredible and I really really cannot
wait to get my hands on it because like
this like the graphics look amazing the
gameplay looks unique and like the
characters look really fun but anyways
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me at mess
retainment on Twitter if you guys want
to see me tweet some weird stuff but
more importantly you can follow new
rockstars anywhere we are on the social
medias and again do not forget to check
out Immortals of AVM whenever you get
the chance because this game is going to
be incredible but yeah thank you guys so
much for watching this video and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye